authorities are wondering if the masked
vigilante who terrorized the city's
underworld is back
the past is caught up with me
should we be worried no no it's nothing
i'll be over christmas i promise first
things first jeremy i'm going to start
with you so
this is a 10-year journey to this moment
where you know hawkeye finally gets to
shine with his sort of like standalone
series uh just talk about what it was
like when they told you they were going
to do it and how it feels to come to
this point in the journey
uh exciting um it was
super super exciting uh back then when
we were discussing it and uh
even more exciting now that it's done
and we get to share it
um haley i'll bring it to you because
it's crazy to think of it but this this
whole mcu universe sort of grew up
alongside you in a lot of ways and so
yeah talk about
joining it and then yeah what that
moment was like when you found out and
you're feeling about the mcu in general
uh yeah i mean i'll never forget uh that
phone call that i got uh when i found
out that this would be a reality for me
something that i
never would have believed could be um
being a part of the mcu so i feel
incredibly honored um so grateful very
lucky
uh
and i've had such an amazing time and
and i feel a part of a show i'm very
proud of and very excited about um
yeah can't wait for people to see it
uh jeremy what's interesting about this
when i was talking to reese is he said
he really liked playing up the sort of
like you at the holidays cantankerous a
little bit just trying to get home to
his family and so yeah if you can sort
of like just set up where where hawkeye
is at this moment and just the kind of
maybe the fun you had because i feel
like it's a little bit of a like journey
home story a little bit of a grinch in
there and then kate's just kind of
giving you the business the whole time
yeah yeah but
it's
the guy's carrying a lot on his
shoulders and he's taking his uh kids
out to new york to go see a musical that
he's invited to and yeah i think there's
a lot of
that's the seriousness on him and the
grumpiness comes from like look he wants
to go home to his kids and uh
anything that's in the way of that it's
like it's probably not gonna be the most
pleasant human and i don't think clint
was uh
very pleasant in the beginning of the
show because of that uh and but that's
where a lot of the the beginning of the
humor comes from uh it's all based in
truth right so
and then uh the expression of her
friendship kind of grows into other
things so
i love that and i i would never be sad
having to watch rogers the musical but i
completely understood why clint was not
exactly signing up for that i get it um
haley for you another added bonus of
this is you get to play with all the
like mcu toys to talk about the bow and
arrow training and we're
and i'll ask you jeremy were you giving
her like tips on like be careful it can
like pop back on you or were you guys
trading bow and arrow stories uh it was
very fun to dive into that whole aspect
um i was very intrigued and excited that
that was obviously a very big part of
this show and of kate's world um
yeah i learned a lot very quickly i
learned that we don't use real
arrows
but i still was um very
much like kate excited about the trick
arrows and all the other mcu toys that
year you mentioned uh
but yeah we had a good time with it yeah
what's the biggest thing about doing it
with no arrows like is it just like you
kind of like do you get a you can get
the string with it yeah yeah
okay you still get the string but no
arrows you get the the whole bow just
know yes
um jeremy like i said this is kind of
like a momentous sort of like moment in
the story of clinton and hawkeye but
you've got had a lot over the history
starting with the first one in thor when
you're just taking aim at poor chris
hemsworth as thor but what's been your
favorite you know moment while you've
gotten to play this character
or you know one that you just
particularly marked with fondness
uh yeah uh it's it's not any one moment
in the
in in the work of it i think it's it's
in the value of friendships that i
that was bestowed on to me because of it
over the last decade
um and made a lot of great friends and
then
forever friends that's such a pretty
amazing that's a really sweet one i was
hoping you were going to say singing the
i'm a superhero
2 song on jimmy fallon because that is
one of my all-time favorite moments
yeah i forgot about that
like i'm sorry chipotle uh extra
chipotle's
real quick there's a lot of folks that
get introduced into this series and it
seems like with every show we get to
meet new characters but if you could
think about anyone in the mcu that has
already sort of been introduced that you
would like to see kate bishop either go
toe to toe with or team up with besides
hawkeye who would you like to see her
sort of interact with in later episodes
maybe oh man
there's way too many you can name a run
girl nobody's gonna hold you to it it's
your show you know wow
the possibilities are really endless
aren't they
uh
yeah i don't even know where i'd begin
also i feel like kate wouldn't either so
so uh i'll have to think about that
oh all right i'm just going to picture
you hanging out with valkyrie because
that just makes my heart sing
when i wore this suit
i made a whole lot of enemies
you're a hawkeye i'm gonna start with
this because it's kind of kate bishop's
torment the fact that you guys are a
couple um so maybe you can fill folks in
on you guys oh no we can't feel foot we
don't know what her problem is we really
don't i can see why she would be hyper
suspicious of a guy who comes in and
takes all the artwork down and puts up
swords and decorates it i mean with his
sword fetish
he's a sword fetishist that's more what
it is it's not the swordsman it's the
sword machine
what is that about yeah sure
well just bringing can't have a hobby
these days
without being suspicious
i mean i give it for kate that's kind of
like
i'm being completely unfair completely
hasn't seen anyone since he lost her
husband i mean it's like
kind of outrageous if you think about it
i love how you're giving her no recorder
yeah you know kids these days kids these
days
they want all the fun
well tony i'll bring it to you um
you've played a villain you know a
couple of times before uh you know we're
gonna talk about the better call stall
but i'm just curious is there something
particularly fun about maybe paying the
bad guy or maybe what some people would
think is the bad guy
um
yeah yeah it's great because you uh
you know you you keep them guessing you
don't know i i you don't know if uh if
if jack duquesne is the bad guy or not
he could just be the greatest guy in the
world so
i mean
i i kind of feel bad that you're saying
that about me it's like you don't even
know me and you're already telling me
i'm the bad guy
i mean judgey
why why why what it's like if i said
something about you and you did you
didn't know the sword said it i mean
what just a couple swords on the wall
and now
some people i couched it some people may
think you're the bad guy i think you're
lovely
i do i think they're lovely this is how
we start our interview this
you just think he's just the worst guy
in the world not me just because kate
thinks i'm a bad guy doesn't mean i'm a
bad guy yeah i think kate's got all the
answers yeah exactly definitely not i
roll up a clock tower i mean come on
talk about bad guys
i have to add this though real quick
since you are in both worlds and
mcu fans are insane and so better call
saul fans have you gotten to experience
a little bit of both do you have any
observations between the two fandoms
uh no i have no idea
i mean we're just getting started here
and also with the whole pandemic thing i
don't even i mean you just don't you
know you don't you don't really get to
go out or see anybody so i'm not really
that um oh they'll find you
they'll find you don't worry they will
find you
yeah
um vera so obviously you play uh you
play uh alongside haley and i just want
to talk about her you've already given
her the business but just talk about
working with her because i know she was
so great in this series and she's talked
already about how great it was working
with you she's so great i i can't speak
just she is um she's a very talented
young woman she's fierce she fears she
rises to every occasion look she's
she kills it she kills it in this role
she's fierce every which way you know
how she delivers emotionally in this
role but physically as well
watching her do the acrobatics and the
fighting sequences and
and uh the sword fighting with you and i
mean anything you throw in front of her
she's just like yeah sure let's do it
and she gets it done i don't think
there's any more you can say she's
amazing i love i love that specifically
but i do have to ask both of you because
joining on the series side but also
after 26 films and i think now we're on
series uh the fifth series what was it
about joining this sort of like
cinematic universe was it just the part
or did you like have somebody in your
family being like if you get to be in a
marvel movie you have to say yes and
vera i'll start with you
yeah
i mean i knew that would be the coolest
ant in the world if i accepted the role
but i mean i accepted the role but
there's still i mean the marvel process
is a very mysterious one
i mean i don't sometimes know what i'm
entirely in for i didn't know what i was
entirely in for when i said yes to the
role so it's like kind of go with the
flow process with marvel which is
actually terribly exciting
i like that
i still don't know if i'm in it
i have to think i am but i don't know
him i don't know if i can even say that
i'm in this yet and i'm saying you're
giving me an interview so i haven't told
anybody you're very much in it don't
worry about that but but i will bring it
back to that what enticed you to sort of
join in was it the character did you
particularly have anybody encouraging
you or were you an mcu fan yourself
i mean yeah i've seen the movies i like
i love them i think they're great um
i i just i just found it very
interesting that uh i was you know being
offered this this part of uh of the
swordsman you know i just i just like it
was just so surreal because it was also
it was right in the middle of you know
the heart of the whole pandemic so then
it was kind of like you know get on a
plane go to new york uh do this and it's
like really this are you sure like i
said i still i'm still not sure if i did
that or not you know i mean it's just so
it was just so weird and surreal but i
mean it's specific i mean it's a sword
it's like someone gives you a hatchet
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or like that's
it there or like art shirt right it's
just like yeah it's a swordsman that's
cool yeah and there's comic books about
the guy and everything and you're like
oh yeah let's do that let's do that that
sounds like fun things of god
more complicated
[Music]
i think the first thing i would ask you
is what really sort of drew you to the
hawkeye character and what did you find
um so compelling about him his humanity
i mean he's a he he to me is is the you
know one of the relatable characters
yeah in the avengers and um you know i i
always found you know clint's ark
through the mcu
again just really interesting like his
family life um
and also the way you know there's that
scene with with with wander and ultron
and and obviously his relationship with
natasha sort of i i feel like he was he
was the character that sort of truly
kind of understood the the price of what
they were doing you know because again
his superpower is it's who he is and and
um not not necessarily what he can do um
you know and so i found that you know an
interesting dynamic to explore and then
you know and then within that we had the
fraction run which to me again if
it's when i
when i read that comic
were i again gonna write a comic about a
character that that's it's such a
perfect way to sort of look at the
absurdity of that situation um
and have fun with it right again rather
than making it sort of dark and brooding
yeah and then sort of talking about you
know jeremy i mean he's been playing
this character for over a decade and so
coming in at this point and giving him
the biggest spotlight he's ever had even
in that decade um how did you guys sort
of start those conversations because
again this is not just a movie this
comes in with like a lot of baggage
behind it yeah but you know again jeremy
has lived this and and
and again we've lived alongside him as
fans and and um and so
you know ultimately again you start you
know you start having conversations
about this character and these moments
from his past i'm i'm sort of i know you
realize that you're talking about it in
this almost sort of shared cultural
history you know the the you know again
i'm talking about you know voromir and
natasha
you know like i lived it with him and
and and but you realize with jeremy he
he lived it too it's like it's like he
feels these things um like he's that
sort of actor i think that there's you
know it's an emotional journey that he's
been on with his character so
um you know again it's just this
privilege you get this wonderful actor
but also this deep history that that you
you know you're you're pulling on and
and again it doesn't i can't tell him
anything new it's it's really you know
just giving him the room to to play with
it well he definitely had fun playing
with it i think
besides all the incredible jokes
especially just the fact that haley as
kate bishop just gave him no quarter but
my favorite part as an unabashed theater
kid was the musical within the musical
and so if you could just break down how
that came about because my broadway kid
heart just sang the minute i saw that
uh yeah no we were
again we were essentially you know
trying to figure out just a good way to
meet clint and and
um you know and you know maybe he's in
new york you know with his kids it's
christmas time and and
yeah i just started thinking about what
would what would be the last place that
clinton would want to find himself as a
person and um yeah like watching a
broadway show
about some traumatic moment in his life
felt like the way to do it so yeah i
threw it out as a silly idea um in a in
a meeting kind of you know maybe what if
and kevin
you know kind of jumped on it and then i
immediately tried backtracking because i
i suddenly suddenly realized what it
would mean what we'd have to do but yeah
no we we kept on and i got to work with
mark sheaman and scott whitman on it and
and yes i you know again as maybe some
of my previous work will suggest i i
enjoy um broadway and those musicals so
yeah it was it was kind of fortuitous
yeah i'm actually going to bring it
right now to your previous work because
um a lot of people probably know you
from like the snl stuff and i just have
to ask this question because i feel you
would know better than anyone which
either snl cast member or snl character
would fit best in the world of hawkeye
oh yeah well
my brain i'm just gonna again because i
could spend ages thinking about this but
my brain immediately went to stefan
yes i mean
he's the new york club kid and yeah he's
it's it's that's that is hot so yeah
that's right yeah i would very much like
to see bill hader say
has everything
exactly
just i don't think i can write it as
well as they can um bringing it back to
the more serious side like all of these
shows the incredibleness is even though
they're made for
television as opposed to the big screen
they do not scrimp at all on the action
and there's so much within this i'm just
curious which was the most exciting or
challenging action sequence that you got
to film in the show without you know
maybe spoiling too much
um well we we have a quite a spectacular
finale um you know which which you come
to expect from marvel um
so that was definitely and again i can't
say what it is but uh but yeah tune in
um
that was a big challenge i mean you know
i think the fun of this show again is
the human characters and
you know for the action in general like
my philosophy coming in as just sort of
talking to a stunt coordinator and
talking to um the burst the other
directors when when they came on as well
was i wanted to take the approach
uh you know of again grounding the
action making sure that we never
overwhelmed the reality of these
characters they can't fly they do get
hurt and so trying to maintain that
reality and again to me a good action
sequence is actually usually it's it's
more you know characters bickering in
the middle of it or the story like
that's that's what's memorable to me
we've seen crazy impressive stuff in
other franchises in a novel and i felt
like what we can do is we've got these
great characters and so let's let's kind
of enjoy that ride with them
what specifically excites you about
being a part of it now now that you're
part of the pantheon
i i i it's even you enunciating that i'm
like oh god i'm part of it um yeah you
are no that's it it's marvel it's it's
crazy it's bonkers uh that yeah i mean i
stood in in mcu new york and not just my
the new york i know and and so i got to
do that so i know it's all exciting i
mean it's crazy i got encapsulated
holy [ __ ]
there are arrows more dangerous than
that one i just wanted to talk about you
know when you sort of signed on and
started putting all the pieces together
for this what was the direction you were
sort of hoping to take clint and maybe
show a side that we hadn't seen before
uh that exactly is the reason it was
just showing a different side of clint
um we we have sort of established the
type of character um he
was in avengers right in all of the
avengers movie he's a family man he's a
little bit more serious it was the
ultimate version of the comics but what
i found interesting was there's there's
a different side of clint that we
haven't seen before and it's in some of
the comic runs like fraction that was so
appealing i couldn't put the book down
uh when i started reading it and it was
just a lot of humor and and it was just
the dynamic between the two of them and
it i was trying to figure out well how
do we bring that into the story but not
seem like we're ignoring what we've
established in the last 10 years with
his character um and kate bishop was the
perfect person to sort of get that side
of clint out that no one has um seen yet
so it it it the focus really
is about clint and kate's dynamic and
the friendship and the bond that they've
created and that was what um
what we had in mind in terms of the
light-hearted tone for the series
well and of course haley and jeremy are
just so great together on screen um but
also you know this is now the fifth mcu
series and they've all seemed to just
play in totally different parts of the
universe but if you were sort of looking
at them now with number five what would
you say to folks maybe we're a fan of
the other ones like what makes this one
different
and that is one of the reasons why we
were trying to figure out how we set
this apart from every um
you know every series that has come out
or that will be coming out um and i
think this one is different um
mainly it's a holiday event um i love
christmas i think you know a lot of
people at marvel do and we haven't done
a christmas setting uh since iron man 3.
and who better to bring that to life
than clint barton who is one of the few
avengers who has a family and he is
dealing with the fallout after end game
from losing his family um during the
five years blip becoming ronan um and
then getting his family back um so it's
the pressure of you know wanting to to
be there for the holidays um because
this is the first christmas that they're
having together uh but he's stuck at a
different location because of something
that he can't get out of
and every day that he is missing um is
time spent with them and the big
question is is he going to be able to
make it home in time for for the
holidays
yeah it is very plains trains and
automobiles yeah way higher stakes
as we talk about you know haley
stanfield's version of kate bishop i
know that the fracture run series the co
in the comics was something that you
pulled a lot from on both clint and kate
bishop but what particularly about haley
in her um sort of casting what elements
of that character from the comics did
you feel she was going to be the perfect
person to play
well i mean
haley is is an incredible actor i mean
look at the body of work she um
uh she has done and i think you know one
of my favorites of hers is true grit and
i think there's that that that sort of
spunk she has
and that is kate bishop all the way
right kate from the comics is just she
speaks her mind she's not afraid to do
so she's strong-minded um and she's got
you know wits and she's smart and i
think
there is um you know uh haley carries
that in her performances and we knew
that there was a version of kate and it
was just finding that right person for
it and as soon as haley you know walked
into uh the marvel office it was just
like this is her this is arcade bishop
and to see it on screen and she did an
amazing job it was just we're so happy
with everything that she has you know
brought to the table for this character
i love that one of the great things
about marvel both on the film side and
on the television size they seem to just
assemble a crew of you know like
dedicated comic book nerds both with you
and rhys and obviously kevin at the at
the top of that but i'm just curious
what can um mcu or comic fans what
little easter egg should they maybe be
looking out for maybe not even specific
ones maybe there's an episode or a
moment that you want folks to maybe
scroll into the background to see if
they can pick up something you know i
have to say out of all of the
maybe even all of the other projects
that i've worked on this one probably
has the most
uh comic nods
because there were so many good elements
in
um
in the comics that i just was just
trying to put all as much as i can in
and um and obviously sadly you know some
of it had to go as we were tightening
you know the story lines and some ended
up on the cutting uh room floor but
um we tried to preserve as much as
possible i think there are it's
scattered throughout the episode so i
think you know as soon as you see the
rest of it i'm dying to know how people
are going to be picking up on the pieces
that we've you know included in there
well i'm just i'm just going to say that
they're sprinkled throughout like a
lovely pizza we'll find those toppings
as it goes but there you go
you set the stage i think quite well for
maybe more story in season two if you do
get to do a season two is there any
areas or stories or maybe characters
that you would like to see explore uh
you know obviously our focus is let's
get this one right and make sure that
everybody's gonna be happy with this one
um and then we can go from there
yes there are you know
my mind's constantly going and it won't
stop and there's there's obviously a lot
more to to tell
if the time is right um and the space is
right in order to
um uh get us to where we need um in in
the the overall mcu
well they trained you so well you didn't
give me anything in that question i
appreciate you
you know what
uh after infinity war an end game where
i couldn't say a single thing i'm
actually so glad that i can say a little
bit of something here you're great
you're trained well thank you so much
thank you have a great day it's a
pleasure meeting you
you